THE GAME IS ON.
AGAINST ST. LOUIS.
A BIG
A FANCY MOVE AND GETS
IT ON ULLMARK.
WH BY
DUCLAIR.
JUMPS PAST HAULA,
GIVES THE PUCK DEEP.
DUCROSS-CHECKING.
>> ANDY: GREAT
PASSERS OF HIS ERA.
CHIPPED IN FRONT. THAS
OFF FROM THE LEFTBERG!
INTO THEMARCHAND TO B!
STOP.
>> JACK: HAGG, A SOFT
ICE.
IT'S GOING TO BE OP
LAY
ON THE PUCK BECAUSE
FLORIDA
INTENTIONALLY WIDE.
MARCHAND SLIPS THE
PUCK TO BARKOV, TO
A GOAL!
>> ANDY:GET A LOOK ATA
SCORE BY DEBRUSK LAW!
ON GOAL BY MARCHAND
IS CRITICAL.
FREDERIC.
COYLE GOES DOWN
BEHIND THE
JUST MISSED.
>> JACK: LINDHOLM
DEBRUSK, COYLE THERE.
A RETURN MONTOUR,MOST.
HALL, GOOD BODY
POSITION.
BERGERON TO PASTRNAK,S
FOR DAVID PASTRNAK.
THATERON.
BERGERON, HALL,
STOPPED BY BOBROVSKY!
THE LINEUP.
PASTRNAK MOVES IT
ACROSS BERGERON.
MARCHAND.
MARCHAND THE CROWD IS1
DEFENSE, THAT IS BA